in keeve there is a defiant celebration
residents are out unafraid and active
call it the new normal
months ago people hid in bomb shelters
fearing the russian invasion but
ukraine's troops pushed them back and
now the battle lines are far away
so normal life slowly coming back to key
if we open right now much more
restaurants cafe it's
the business coming back and this
slowly starting to work
but
it's illusion
blue sky sunshine summer
and
we have never forget this couple of
hundred kilometers east of kiev it's
hell
it's big battle where our patriots
defend our country
the city's famous opera house is open
but no one has forgotten that this is a
country at war and not far off we're not
in kharkiv which is
under shelling every day we're not it's
like in dunbar somewhere
so
me yeah no like we're not scared
tourists from the other parts of ukraine
have returned to their capital
this might be a war zone but it doesn't
have to feel like one and that's the
point these people are out despite the
occupation
as difficult as it is the residents of
kiev say life goes on
i had to flee to other countries because
it was too scary to stay in ukraine
but now i'm back and it's still
spooky every day when we have airways
sirens
everything has changed but we need to
move forward
and to leave
for the youth of kyiv the rave parties
downtown go on though they now start at
5 pm in order to end in time for curfew
amid the fog of war the celebration the
defiant insistence on living something
like normal life continues
john hendren al jazeera keef